world, most people will want some sort
of assistance.
I've been talking I've been doing this
for 24 years. Um, in 2002, I stood in
HSBC's headquarters in London showing
them how to transfer money around the
room using mobile phones, 2G mobile
phones and GPS mobile phones. You're
probably not even old enough to remember
GPRS. Um,
but we were transferring money and
certificates around the room with mobile
phones in 2002. Uh, that was the first
iteration of what I've built here. And,
um, I said then that the future of
banking was more profitable for less
risk and with none of the headaches that
they have today, maintaining
infrastructure that they think are
assets but actually are liabilities in
order to deliver a service where they
actually add value. Um, I think that the
future of banking will be most people
will want to have somebody provide
safekeeping and care for them because
they don't want to be responsible for
themselves. Those of us who do want to
be responsible for ourselves have that
right, have that capacity. We don't have
that at the moment, but that's where we
should get to. Um, and I think most
people will still want to have City
Bank, for example, or Wells Fargo on the
app that they access to see their
wallet.